- Abigail Adams was
really very smart.
When you look back, you think,
"Wow, what could she have done,
if she had had the kind of
education women have today?"
She could've ruled the world.
John Adams served
in the Congresses,
he served as a diplomat,
he became president,
they were more often
apart than together.
And so The Book of
Abigail and John,
of exchanges of
letters between them,
is one of the most read
by colonial historians
that include a woman,
that we've ever had.
- She was a wonderful writer.
There is a kind of
fluency to her language,
it's almost
Shakespearian at times.
She really understood
the human condition,
and drew upon it.
- Abigail was very supportive
of her husband as First Lady,
but she was not much
of an entertainer.
- She really hammered
home this importance
of virtue and education
and everything
that went into making a model
citizen, and she lived it.
- She carried with her that
idea that in a republic,
simplicity, hard work,
distaste for luxuries
ought to be the cultural norm.
She's the first First Lady
to occupy the White House,
and Abigail makes
use of the house
in such a New England
housewife way.
She hangs her laundry
up in one of the rooms.
You could've
predicted that Abigail
was not going to fancy up the
White House, and she didn't.
Abigail is often touted as
the first feminist in America
because she wrote
"Remember the Ladies",
the single most
misinterpreted letter ever
in the history of America.
Almost everyone believes that
she was asking her husband
that women be given the vote,
but that was the farthest
thing in the world
from Abigail's mind.
- She was actually calling
for legal protections
within marriages.
At the time, a wife
was really considered
the property of her husband,
he could do, kind of,
whatever he wanted with her.
- She was asking for a
revision of marriage laws
that gave everything
that a woman owned
from her dowry to her
clothes on her back
to her body, to her husband.
- She was urging her
husband to remember that
men could be really
brutal to women.
- She was saying, we fought
for liberty and independence
and freedom. Give women
a little independence!
She understood that
economic dependency
was what kept women restrained.
His reply to her
was to laugh at her.
Men would be crazy to
give into what she want.
Had they gotten the married
women's property law
when Abigail wanted it, the
whole history of American women
might be different.